let me start off by saying that this
film is not for everybody i can see how
a lot of people will love this film but
i can also see how a lot of people will
be really bored it really requires your
intellect your concentration i sometimes
got a little lost i'll start by saying
that this movie is obviously about the
journey not the ending if you complain
about the film saying oh we all know how
it ends and you're a [ __ ] idiot but i
will also say that for a film that we
all know the conclusion too it's still a
rather long movie but then i'd also say
it's the details of every moment that
make it so great hands down the
directing and writing is phenomenal it's
authentic super believable the directing
has that sort of handheld makes you feel
like you're watching a documentary with
all the shakiness i know that wasn't the
same thing but no you really feel like
you're in this hell jessica chastain
deserves an oscar for this movie plus
she's hot jason clark at least deserves
a nomination the acting is pretty much
perfect the movie is intense and i mean
intense when it needs to be and
regardless of knowing what happens to
bin laden the film still provides us
with a brilliant intensely moving final
act ryan wright says this film got it
right